不是瞒着你是杀人放火了，
不是瞒着你去作奸犯科了，
不是瞒着你好乱搞男女关系了，
他只是瞒着你多给他妈妈一点钱了，
就这事儿，
我感觉你要不要你给我得了，
我感觉这男的挺好。
我跟我老公是自由恋爱，
她家是农村的，
是城里的，
我结婚的时候房子车都是我们家买的，
她家就没有出什么钱，
在她家条件特别不好，
后来我跟大姐挺开心，
怀孕的时候发现了她有私房钱，
我就一下子怀疑到了她，
但是我也选择原谅她了，
她说她有主衷什么的，
因为条件不好，
毕竟家里付出全部的了。
后来我一直感情多少有点隔阂了，
但是她有多少私房钱呀，
2万多吧，
因为我们工资都很少，
很小，
这个城市他就是说说我亏钱没啥概念，
你打车呀，
付费什么的时候，
也可能他就是坐公交车了，
然我打车了，
就这样10块20块这样慢慢涨着的，
也就是说他平时工资是上交给你的，
是从你这儿掏点儿私房钱是吧？
对对，
哎呀，
男人有个2万块钱的私房钱，
这个事情你还不能包容一下吗？
听我说，
因为当初结婚的时候，
因为他给我的太少了嘛，
他说以后挣到的钱都给我，
就是我就感觉这个是我的故事吗？
还是钻牛角尖啊，
我说我就问你啊，
这2万块钱的私房钱，
他有没有拿去给别的女人买花，
给别的女人买金镯子，
给别的女人买。
什礼品，
给别的女人买什么巧克力，
他但凡是没有拿来给别的女人买什么东西，
他只是说他可能又要有个呃，
这个侄女儿结婚了，
他可能给你说给了500，
实际上他给了800，
或者他妈妈过生日了，
他给你说呃，
给的是300，
实际上他给的是500，
就这些事儿的话，
都不叫事儿，
除非你告诉我说龙飞他就是打了2万块钱私房钱，
他给你个女的买了个金镯子，
我都没带上金镯子，
那个女的带上金镯子了，
那就不能用，
除了这种情况，
其他的都不影响是吗？
对呀，
不影响，
我不怀疑她，
她当时跟我在一起是不是因为她条件不好，
我条件好就是，
你懂我意思吗？
来，
姑娘啊，
千万别这么想问题，
条件好是我命好，
她就算是看上我条件好了，
哎呦，
幸好我条件好，
为啥？
因为我喜欢他呀，
我想要他呀，
但是我心里会不平衡，
因为我们所有身边的人都觉得，
就是无论是外貌啊，
还是条件啊，
还是工作呀，
他都是找我这么好的，
唯一好一点，
可能他情绪比我稳定一点儿，
他比较能就是包容一点儿，
那谁让你喜欢他呢？
就是条件没你好，
挣钱没你多，
家境没你好，
架不住你喜欢他呀。
当时继续讲原来了之后，
我后来的时候又发现了，
他就是背着我给他妈妈买东西，
数额了不是很大，
然后该选择原谅了，
后来就跟他谈，
我就想你就不要什么事情，
就是总瞒着我去做，
也许你跟我说出来，
我们商量着了，
就屡教不改。
很多时候别的情况也是，
就可能背着我出去打个麻将啊，
在就是让我很焦虑，
我就感到是不是外面有人了，
就总是这样瞒着我去做一些事情，
但是我没有抓到任何证据，
他总是在强调是我管他管的太严了，
不让他喝可乐，
不让他打麻将，
所以他才会瞒着我，
那后来我就改变我自己，
我说那这么的吧，
我说我的底线就在于这里，
别瞒着我，
我说哪怕你说出来打一架也这样，
就是你瞒着我，
让我这种内耗好。
从第一次感觉到现在我们孩子已经大了，
就是七八年的时间了吧，
那就这一两年，
我发现他又在单位工作的时候，
瞒着我在打麻将，
我就开始特别内耗的，
总想他是不是骗我，
又骗我攒钱了，
又骗我外面有什么别的事情了，
已经持续两年了，
就到昨天给你说，
我如果再发现攒钱的事情的话，
我们就离婚，
孩子给我，
你给我抚养费，
那前几天我又发现他这种事情了，
他已经知道事情的严重性了，
然后还是去瞒着我又给他妈妈钱，
哎呀，
我咋说呢，
这个事儿呢，
他不是瞒着你，
是人放火了，
不是瞒着你去作奸犯科了，
不是瞒着你去搞乱搞男女关系了，
他只是瞒着你多给他妈妈一点钱了，
就这事儿，
我感觉你要不要你给我得了，
我感觉这男的挺好，
没姐为啥不能说出来呢？
因为你强势啊，
因为你小心点啊，
因为你过分啊，
哪个男的跟你过也得藏点私房钱呀，
不然的话被你管的这么死。
那还活不活人了是吗？
真的，
前妹啊，
知足吧，
这男的踏踏实实工作，
他只是有点孝心，
悄悄的给他妈妈几个钱儿，
他没有干什么伤天害理的事儿，
没有干什么作奸犯科的事，
那如果我跟他讲，
我说候，
你可以告诉我，
因为他了解你，
我告诉他，
我同意，
他也还会瞒着我，
你是这个意思吗？
姑娘啊，
很多东西你要对人性要有一个充分的认知，
水至清则无鱼，
即便是两口子之间的话，
他是一个独立的人，
他要有自己的自私的部分，
他不可能所有的领空、
领土、
领地全都对我开放，
他会有自己的一个自流地，
他可能是个自由流地，
种点儿鲜花，
种点儿我平时你吃了会过敏的一些东西，
他自己喜欢吃，
明白这个意思吗？
因为人都一样，
包括你也应该是这样的，
就是你只是跟他结了个婚，
领个结婚证，
并不是把你的所有的身心，
所有的空领土领地全都奉献给这个人，
我们作为女人也要有一片儿我自己的小自留地，
我这个小自留地可能是我喜欢吃大蒜，
我就种大蒜，
我喜欢吃折耳根，
我就种折耳根，
我喜欢吃香菜，
我就种香菜，
并不是要所有的领土领地领空全都开放给他，
不是的，
每个人都应该有一点自己的小小的这个私个地好不好？
那总是觉得就瞒着这些人就会没有，
也妹有啊，
瞒着才是。
常态就你都不稀的管才对，
你都不应该稀的管他给他妈妈花了多少钱才对，
我听别人说的不会太心，
你这么跟我说的话，
我可能会反思我自己了，
你的意思就是我不去管这个事情了，
如果你说这种事情瞒着我，
比如说女人什么事情瞒着我呢？
我就会很担心，
那就干他，
你如果说他在外面跟别的女人乱狗，
给别的女人花钱，
那就干，
就把房子车子什么的该签协议他签协，
他也是正经有工作的人，
那就干他。
那但凡是没有跟别的女人乱搞，
没有给别的女人花钱，
他只是给他妈妈多花了几个钱的话，
那就由着他，
明白的，
谢谢你，
我搞就这样啊，
拜拜，
回头把这个先剪出来，
简这出来，
没别的意思，
姐妹啊，
你可能看到评论区你会生气，
你会不服，
你会心里就觉得，
凭什么大家都在说我，
但是这事儿可能对你会有一个反思的作用，
你就会发现，
只要是个正常的男的，
他都得有私房钱，
他能够做到工资上交，
能够做到就攒了2万块钱，
他没说他攒了20万，
攒了多少钱，
他就攒了个2万块钱的私房钱，
他妈妈不是咱的仇人，
他妈妈不是外人，
他妈妈是养育他的人，
那你说你以后生了个儿子，
儿子挣了工资全给他儿媳妇了，
你过生日的时候，
难道你不希望你的儿子能给你买个金戒指，
买个金项链儿，
买个什么貂儿，
你生个儿子，
你也会有这样的期许吧，
也。
期待你儿子在你过生日的时候，
能在你姐妹的圈子里面能炫耀一下。
哎呀，
我儿子又给我买了个羽绒服，
我儿子又给我买个貂儿，
哎呀，
我儿子又给我买了个金镯子，
我儿子又带我去哪儿旅游了？
你不是也这样吗？
是不是啊？
王菲姐可以讲讲如何把控控制欲吗？
就真的把别人当个人，
把自己当个人就是我们只要做到严于律己，
宽以待人，
真的跟谁都能处挺好。